we are getting a lot of mixed messages
from the government on this including
the prime minister who this morning said
that he would not make misogyny a hate
crime and in this interview
said the word confident the public not
being confident regaining confidence but
shied away from saying ashamed of you
know the police's performance and the
conviction rate so i think it doesn't
it doesn't create a lot of trust for
this government's commitment to this
really important issue
because you know we have um so much
emphasis um even in pretty patel's
speech about wayne cousins and sarah
everard's case
uh without acknowledging that none of
this is new we've had hmi inspectorate
reports from the government's own you
know uh
policies looking at it we've had
violence against women policies and
targets and then the government's own
rape review and none of those things
have led to an improvement the uk has
one of the lowest rate conviction rates
in the world especially in the developed
world and of countries you know at the
same gdp uh level as the uk and i think
that it's it's shocking that when south
africa can have a seven percent rape
conviction rate and india can have
almost 20 percent the uk still cannot
achieve three percent so
uh and
the other thing that i found from the
interview which was really uh important
that we do hear an acknowledgement
though from the prime minister and also
from preethi mateo that they do they
have identified that it is a systemic
issue times are long there's not enough
resources and it's too complex and
people don't trust that their complaints
are gonna be you know heard and that
they're gonna get the
the empathetic treatment that they
deserve as victims and survivors of
violence hera help them out you get it
it seems the political will is there if
we take them at face value you've got
not just the prime minister but you've
got the justice secretary and the home
secretary today saying that violence
against women tackling violence against
women and girls is their number one
priority what's holding them back why
does the prime minister for example
today seem so downcast when it comes to
talking about progress and getting
prosecution rates up and achieving
targets that they themselves set earlier
this summer
it feels like there's you know like
always the government is really keen on
um coming up with policies and
statements that focus on the short term
and and because violence against women
is something that you know create it
needs a whole system to work together
and radical change to happen
for us to come you know anywhere close
to reducing the levels of abuse that
women face
they there is a lack of lack of
recognition of that so for example you
know we know that um the we know that
there's almost one woman every week
reports a police officer for sexual
assault or domestic abuse it's not new
we've heard from police officers many
times female police officers that say
they don't feel confident when they go
to uh have complaints against their male
uh counterparts that those in complaints
are going to be investigated more than
600 police officers have had complaints
of you know gender-based violence
against them
and in the last 10 years so we we none
of this is new what we need is radical
change in the way police are vetted
they're trained they get less than half
a day's training on trauma and
psychology at the moment
and like more robust processes when you
have complaints coming up against
officers that those are investigated
whether they're from the inside or
outside and more importantly you know
the police's databases don't match at
the moment they don't link up so if you
have a
an allegation a charge in one police
station there's a very good chance if
you are working another police station
or you are a perpetrator who's been
brought in into the station at another
place that will not get caught up and
that just feels like a ver it's a thing
that is actually in the short term can
be fixed but isn't done and then the
more complex things require things like
education on consent in schools so we
stop the problem before it becomes a big
offense and
having clear legislation around misogyny
being a hate crime would go a long way
and this was a very clear policy
decision that could have been made and
could have been announced it would have
been a big success in the government
listening to victims and survivors and
campaigners but they haven't done that
so you know it leaves us in this
uncertain position where they've they
say it's a it's a really high priority
but they can meet their own targets and
they can't follow their own strategies
and we get
we get mixed messages about where those
resources are going
the government has control of the public
purse they have you know the police
and the policies and the internal
culture again it has there have been
reports about that so why hasn't change
happened until now and what's different
about this particular time
hera
it's been quite a couple of weeks the
the murder of sabine anessa and sarah
everard the conviction um the conviction
of her murderer has
put this issue of violence against women
and girls back in the spotlight and we
need
to keep it there
can we take any positivity out of this
moment i understand that your
organization has had a lot of victims
come forward wanting to tell their story
so they can keep this momentum going and
you've also had a lot of men come
forward male allies because of course
the onus is always on women
to deal with this problem but actually
it's men who are creating this problem
and they need to address it
absolutely you know this violence woman
is a male problem it is you know women
take a lot of responsibility for looking
after themselves and
you know
making plans about the littlest of
things what am i wearing who am i going
to see what time of the day is what food
am i going to take what should i do if
i'm approached by a police officer
exactly you know so these unhelpful tips
from the police as if we've not been
through all of that already in our head
doesn't really help but what i've been
really enthused by is the fact that men
are asking what can they do
um and you know the the thing that
everyone can do especially men is is
educate themselves listen to the women
in your life listen to
you know
campaigners academics researchers
survivors that are sharing their stories
believe them and then take actions
around them when is the last time you
spoke to your son your brother your
friends about consent about the way you
know if are they having any problems in
their relationships and if so have you
tried talking to them about that how do
they react to stress you know uh have
you interrupted a rape joke before have
you tried to take these small
interventions have you asked about equal
pay in your workplace have you you know
rather than focusing on things that
people often do like let's give women
rape alarms or don't follow women at
night you should not follow anyone
closely at night you know irrespective
of their gender but what you really can
do is have those conversations in the
places that you have power your whatsapp
chats your facebook groups your gym your
friends your workplace your family so
those are the conversations that men are
having now and that gives me so much
hope for a more equal future